politischer aschermittwoch der spd in
dortmund das postengeschacher um den
spd-vorsitz reicht mir
deshalb bringe ich meinen eigenen
kandidaten gleich mit und wo finde ich
den in irgend einer kneipe bernd
borowski groschek wir haben ein gerüst
die hand was los so noch gar kein geld
gemacht oder leicht zu belustigen
herrmann
[Musik]
borowski kommt woher ich komme hier ist
eigentlich egal
er hat ja nicht egal wo sie herkommen da
kann man jetzt mal ein bisschen
konkreter seien aus remscheid kommen und
sie haben also schwer bock den job zu
machen
keine ahnung
er hat keine ahnung kann ideen aber es
hat sich bei martin schulz ja auch nicht
gestört
ach ja das könnte vielleicht eine ganz
gute voraussetzungen seien war der ist
mit dem wollen sie wollen immer nur die
besten warum kriegen sie denn nicht das
ist ja auch die frage nach oben doch wie
viele jahrzehnte üben sie noch weiter
das ist eine wellenbewegung auf und ab
geht wobei die welle er unten ist gerade
recht wer wäre für sie der beste spd
parteivorsitzende
gar keiner wir nehmen in al islam war
nicht wir nehmen den herren borowski
beruf nehmen wir nicht genehme weil ich
sagen sie mal herr woraus die frau
nahles ist die geeignete und die würde
man die stimme kriegen und unterstützung
gut aber sie ist eine frau für das macht
doch nichts und wir brauchen doch frauen
ja aber nicht in der politik also zur
vermehrung brauchen wir frauen aber
nicht in der politik ja das ist der
größte schwachsinn
also dann sind sie auf dem falschen
dampfer wer so was sagt ist absolut
diszipliniert
diese schon gespannt auf die rede von
konamis herrlich ja nein da haben wir
was gemeinsam
ich denke schon wenn sie sprechen kann
ständig wird glauben nichts mehr
herumkommt also ich würde mich auf ein
duell zwischen frau nahles und mir
freuen und zwar nackt auf den tisch bis
es quietscht und ich gewinne
das sag ich
würden sie damit machen normales banales
sie können wieder gehen wir haben den
neuen vorsitzenden herrn borowski herr
borowski sagen sie mal bätzing
das ist doch fantastisch der mann ist
seit 35 jahren in der unglücklichen
beziehungen und trennt sich trotzdem
nicht von seiner frau sehen sie die
parallele die cdu sehen sie die
parallele habe ja auch ein problem haben
[Gelächter]
finden sie denn dass frauen generell
auch geeignet sind für den parteivorsitz
finden sie ja männer auch und menschen
und überhaupt ja menschen die denken
können werden wir meiner liebsten
menschen die demokratie verstehen und
sie dann auch noch machen weil es ist
einfach schlichtungsstelle blöde arbeit
und wäre ihre partei bereit gewesen für
noch mehr posten auf noch mehr inhalt zu
verzichten sicherheit ich den eindruck
habe ich und sie sind trotzdem in der
partei noch wie lange noch
fahrstunden paar stunden entfernt sagt
gibt es mit ok und mitnehmen wollte
andrea geben wenn ich sie kriegen kann
geben machen von wem von drinnen andrea
schwierigste geht es hier
danke
was mein wort ne frau nahles
ich habe mir eine retour
ok dann nehmen sie sehr borowski sind
jedoch kein mittel
[Musik]
schon von außen
[Applaus]